Speaker 1: OK, this you have to see in the
aftermath of the last presidency, some media
outlets have continued to interview the children
of the former guy, really his two adult sons,
Donald Trump Jr. and occasionally Eric Trump.
Eric Trump is nowhere near as he's nowhere
near as good as Don Jr. during these TV appearances.
And he appeared on the Greg Kelly Newsmax
show and delivered a bizarre nearly two minute
word salad that truly rivals anything we've
heard from Donald Trump himself.
Apparently, the apple really doesn't fall
far from the tree.
And I challenge you to tell me, what on earth
is Eric Trump talking about?
The headline at the bottom of the screen.
Presumably the topic of the interview is what
is Joe Biden do in a day now without even
seeing what Eric Trump says?
It's already funny because Donald Trump played
golf on something like the 18 or 19 percent
of the days of his presidency.
He essentially did no real work during the
last six to eight months of that presidency.
But somehow now the story is what exactly
is Joe Biden doing?
Put that aside.
Watch this and I challenge you.
Tell me what Eric Trump is even talking about.
See if you can figure it out.
Well, I
Speaker 4: mean, my whole life, Craig, I've
seen it right.
I mean, when I was when I was a kid, he'd
call me a 6:00 in the morning.
Honey, are you up?
Good.
You better be up.
You know, he'd call me at eleven o'clock at
night again.
Test me.
I mean, my father's just a guy who's never
stopped.
His entire life has been like that.
Whether it's in business, no matter what,
he sets his mind to The Apprentice, et cetera,
et cetera, the presidency, the way he campaigned.
I mean, there's never been a person in political
history that campaigned as hard as my father
has and frankly, as hard as our our family
did.
And, you know, when you saw Biden, I was talking
about obviously, you know, Biden not leaving
his basement in Wilmington, Delaware, right
there.
But, you know, you see these farmers, I go
all over the country.
You'd be with coal miners, you'd be with farmers,
you'd be with first responders, cops.
They're just great Americans that own small
businesses, etc..
Right.
You know, these people are up at five o'clock
in the morning and they don't come back sometimes
until midnight, you know, from work.
And sometimes you're working two and three
jobs and, you know, you're the president of
the United States.
I mean, you should set an example.
And the one thing that no one could ever say
about my father, as crazy as the media was,
right, there's no person in the media as much
hatred as there often was from my father who
wouldn't say that he was the hardest working
president this country has ever had.
Speaker 1: And OK, so before we get to what
I'm sure is just a riveting and compelling
story from Eric Trump, I guess first, Eric
Trump is talking about how hard his dad worked
when he was president, and then he's talking
about how hard some farmers work.
And it's all meant to make Joe Biden look
bad.
Is that the gist of this?
Even the hosts starting to look at look a
little bit confused.
Let's now listen to Eric Trump's anecdote.
And I'm sure it's just endlessly inspirational.
Speaker 4: And Greg, just kind of funny little
anecdote.
I remember so many different people from New
York Times, etc.
They'd be following him rally at a rally to
rally.
These are twenty five year olds.
They would be sleeping in a backpack in the
back of an auditorium after the rally with
three Red Bulls, three empty Red Bulls next
to them totally passed out.
They couldn't keep up with him yet.
You know, he's delivering hours and hours
of speeches to different crowds where he has
to keep such mojo, such energy going the entire
time, such passion going.
I mean, he would literally run these young
kids who were following him around the press
pool.
He would run them into the ground.
And, you know, that's what this country needs.
And, you know, you look at around the world,
at the world leaders, you know, do we think
Putin has energy?
Do we think, you know, go down the list?
I mean, these guys have, you know, men and
women have tremendous work ethic.
Speaker 1: It's funny how the first guy he
thinks of to praise for his energy is Vladimir
Putin, like down to every detail.
This is just hilarious.
And there's a certain disconnect from reality
where Eric Trump says, listen, for all the
things that were said about my dad, no one
could say that he didn't work hard.
And the opposite is true.
Trump golf, the historic amount more than
any other President Trump had endless so-called
executive time on his schedule, which just
means kind of hanging around watching TV hours
and hours every single day.
Trump often wouldn't come down to the Oval
Office to even ostensibly start working until
ten, eleven, noon.
Even Trump stopped even pretending to do work
for the final six to eight months of his presidency.
And towards the end of that, they weren't
even publishing a schedule.
They were simply putting out every day a note
that said the president will work from early
in the morning until late in the evening.
He will have many phone calls in many meetings,
like they weren't even pretending to claim
that Donald Trump was working towards the
end.
It's the opposite of what Eric Trump says
was true about Donald Trump's work ethic.
Now one other.
Eric's big example of Trump's hard work is
Trump did lots of rallies, this actually relates
to something significant.
Doing rallies isn't work.
It's not being the president.
And in fact, Donald Trump was so obsessed
with getting back to rallies even during the
pandemic, that it was part of the reason he
wasn't doing any real work during the last
half year of his presidency.
But that's what they all see as doing work
and as being busy.
And there's just a fundamental misunderstanding,
a lack of understanding as to what it is a
president should or could even be doing.
And then, you know, praising Putin at the
end is just sort of the cherry on top.
I don't know why Eric keeps doing interviews.
Don Junior says disastrous, crazy and dishonest
things, but he's better on TV.
Eric just seems confused and half of what
he says is completely unintelligible.